the the basic premise of fi and sort of
like the enormous promise that i was
supposed to
supposed to bring is that you can build
a financial system
that is trustless you don't have to
trust any middlemen like banks or
traders or
any other type of agent and then you
just trust the code in the system
and the big irony here is that if you
take a justice system
and build it on uh on a type of money
that is highly dependent on trust of the
issuer of the regulator
and the changes in global regulatory
climate then in that case building a
decentralized application on top of
monies like that doesn't really make
sense um
so yeah so to just help the audience
who's new to this
i think everybody understands why stable
coins exist
now you're saying hey these stable coins
are going to get regulated
and who knows what the people running
these stable coins who knows if you can
trust them who knows what regulations
they have today
not many and which ones will come in the
future so
while usdc circles
a stable coin is going to be a public
company and it's in the united states
and it's being audited by u.s
auditors or it's being they have
attestations from u.s auditors
something like tether is you know
obviously a little bit more opaque what
are you doing then if you're not holding
the uh peg to dollars and you don't have
a bank account with them
then where is the money and for your
stable coin living and then maybe also
you could
explain to people what's a what's a
functional definition of defy
got it uh so that's a lot there
but let's start with the functional
definition of d5 what does it mean
yeah so the functional definition of
fifa is that if you look at traditional
finance
most of what happens is based on sort of
a hierarchy of centralized middlemen
so for example if you look at you know
the u.s economy everything starts from
the fed in the us government
and then there's a consortium of
commercial banks that do business
or have an exclusive rights to do
business with the central bank
and then fintech gaps and so on and so
forth so
how the system works is that you need to
trust uh middlemen
at each step of the layer in order for
the financial system to all work in
decentralized finance the idea is that
you don't need to have any one of those
middlemen right you can just simply
put your trust or at least have literacy
in the code that you happen to be
running
for let's say your savings app for your
lending needs uh for your
fx swaps and so on and so forth got it
so we talked a little bit about how you
know
other stable coins are keeping some sort
of assets
and these are now tens of billions of
dollars i think circle is at 26 billion
and
uh tether was at 63 billion less they
checked so these are very large pools of
capital
if i were to buy terra or
i'm not sure what you call your coin is
it just called the terra
is that my correct and calling it that
terra usd yes
terry usda so if i were to buy a terra
usd dollar
for a dollar where does the dollar go
where does it live
what happens uh so terra usd
is in sort of a burgeoning class of
stable points called
algorithmic data points and the idea is
there that
while the currency remains itself pegged
to a fiat currency like the dollar
it's not backed explicitly by a dollar
in the bank account
instead it uses a set of game
theoretical incentives that live
on a blockchain to make sure that the
currency retains its value against the
dollar
so the mechanism is relatively pretty
simple and uh there's
you know sort of like um a rich
ecosystem of fast followers that are
doing very similar things
but the idea is that for every tera
stablecoin that's issued
you need to burn a dollar's worth of uh
an ecosystem token called luna
and vice versa when you're looking to
redeem one pair of usd
you can burn that para usd and then mint
one dollars of luna
at any given time so the idea is that
when terra usd due to
increase in demand starts trading
slightly above a dollar let's say
uh a dollar and 10 cents an arbitrager
has an incentive to burn a dollar's
worth of luna
and then mint one tera usd and then sell
it into the markets
for one point one dollars thereby
capturing a ten percent art spread
and the reverse direction the same is
true if terra usd is trading at a
discount
you can buy it and then swap it to a
dollars worth of luna and then capture
ten percent art that way
so essentially uh by using a set of
arbitrage mechanisms against the
secondary currency
uh carry usd is able to retain its value
okay
so there is a coin called terra
you can buy that where i can go on
coinbase and buy it i can buy it
on your website it exists in on other
exchanges how does one buy terra
and then where does luna exist is this
luna is your currency or it's
some open standard
yeah so uh tera usd you can purchase it
from a number of different exchanges
like bitfinex
uh q coin and um you know lots of
different service providers
uh for luna it's a similar situation
it's a
it's a currency that sort of provides
for network security
of the overall terra blockchain so you
can sort of think about it as a
stability counterpart to para usd
and it also trades quite widely on
various different exchanges
and the price of luna changes but the
price of terra does not
yes got it so when i go on to
one of these exchanges and i deposit
fiat into them they would give me
uh in exchange some lunas or some
terrors
yes got it and then if the tara price
changes
why would the tara price change if it
was pinned to a dollar
sure um so normally it wouldn't but it's
just that most of these cryptocurrencies
trade on order books
right so if there doesn't happen to be
ready inventory available within the
time period that you need it
then in that case um you know due to
supply and demand
if demand demand curve starts to shift
then in that case the price is going to
inch
well why wouldn't you as the person who
controls tara just print more terra
oh so we don't actually print tera so
anybody that has luna tokens can burn it
to
mintera so it's a very decentralized
redemption and its mechanism
so if i own lunas then i can make my own
tarots if i make my own terrors people
could be trading them
they could start to grow in value
and if there weren't enough supply like
there haven't been enough supply of
bitcoins or
ethereum tokens they could go up in
price
but then there's an incentive to then
burn tokens that's the part i don't
understand
sure um so when the incentive to burn
tokens
manifest is if there's too many people
that are selling pair usd so it starts
to trade at a discount
to a dollar in that case you can buy
one pair usd at that discount let's say
10 cents
and then you can swap it on the
blockchain against
one dollars worth of luna token so uh
for example luna right now is around
seven dollars
so if you swap in one pair of usb it's
always going to give you one seventh of
a luna
at that current market price
hey everybody i thought i would bring
christina cassiopo i pronounced it
correct i'm hoping
chris you got it yep all right you're
the founder of vanta
uh people have been hearing your ads on
the pod for the last year
and i thought it'd be fun to have you on
and you to explain
why you created vanta and what sock 2 is
and why it's important people get it
right so let's start with
what is sock 2 for people who are just
realizing they have to become sock 2
compliant for sure
so sock 2 is at its high level
it's sort of a customer asking you to
prove your security so if you've heard
about one it probably comes you're
probably a b2b
company and you're doing sales and
somebody asks you hey can i have your
sock 2 report or you know hey can you go
through security review or
they usually don't phrase it like this
but hey i'm going to put a bunch of data
in your product and i want to know if
you're actually going to be secure or
leak it over the internet
so they ask you to get a stock do report
and these soc2 reports are basically a
third party saying
hey you can trust this company with your
data it's like a standard correct
exactly yeah so a third party auditor
comes in make sure you're in good shape
and writes that report all right thanks
again christina for explaining to us
why this is so important for sas
companies especially when you start
getting into that sales process
and you've been very generous you're
making a nice offer people go to vanta
dot com twist where are they gonna get
christina they're gonna get a thousand
dollars off their manta subscription um
and we're a big fan of twist listeners
oh thanks i know you had a great
response from
our listenership and they always tell
you they found you here so yeah thanks
to our
twist army and we'll see you all next
time bye bye